[Music]
so
so yeah so my talk is sweating the small
stuff recreating subtle design details
using sass
uh and i was gonna have a longer title
but it wouldn't fit so
but my name is tim hetler i'm an open
standards developer at rga
in new york city and so for the next 20
minutes i'm going to be talking about
this button and the process that it took
from going from photoshop comp to
something that is in production today
so
uh
when we were doing a redesign for a
client last year uh we were kind of
embraced progressive enhancement css3
and we're like
we're not going to cut up sprites
anymore we're going to do
we're going to do this with css and so
this is what our designers created in
photoshop we have a normal state and an
active state
and it looks like a pretty
straightforward conversion you know
there's rounded corners gradient
overlays uh text shadows drop shadows it
should be something easy to convert to
css so
the designers just kind of gave the
developers the photoshop file and
they're like all right go to town
and so this is what our developers came
back with and uh this is not
exactly what we're looking for
so that obviously the colors are all
wrong the drop shadows are weird and
they're like i don't know we just looked
at the photoshop file and we just put
everything in and so we started talking
with the designers and the developers
about
like what the problem was and so we
realized in some cases the design what
the designers use to describe something
is different than what the developers
need and in other cases the designers
have vocabulary that the developers just
don't have at all
so um
you know we have a failure to
communicate here designers and
developers aren't speaking the same
language what the designers put into
photoshop isn't what developers need for
css
so how do we solve this translation
issue
well the traditional approach was to
create you know a style guide like this
and this is comically complex and large
you're not supposed to be able to read
what it is but this is actually
what our our designers had to produce
for us because they they stopped
trusting us basically uh to produce to
take our photoshop files and make it in
the css without screwing it up so this
is like we have so many different color
buttons it's an ecommerce site that
we're working for so it was like all
these different buttons and we had to
define the top gradient the bottom
gradient for all the states and also and
there's a second level of complexity
because some of the buttons needed white
text and some of the buttons needed dark
text for contrast reasons so we have
this really kind of complex style guide
and there's a lot of failure points with
this traditional translation process i
mean the designers have to translate
their own designs and then the
developers have to take that file and
then translate it back into css and so
wouldn't it be great if we could cut out
the middleman and we could automate this
translation
well of course we can otherwise my talk
would be really short and so we we can
automate this translation with
preprocessors they can act as the
rosetta stone between designers and
developers and we can use them to
to translate our designs from photoshop
to css flawlessly
and so let's go back and try to rebuild
this button using sas and compass
just a note about the technologies
all my examples are in sas but if you
use less or stylus you can
you can definitely use the same ideas
and if you haven't used a preprocessor
yet your mind is about to explode
because they're amazing and so i'm also
using compass which is a framework
that's built on top of sas which adds a
bunch of mixins and functions to solve a
lot of common problems that we that we
have as developers and compass kind of
it feels like the jelly that goes with
sass peanut butter and so i i
i don't use them separately at all
anymore it's always sas and compass
so um first before we get into like our
translation we have to like build up our
base and we have to sort of build all
the stuff that isn't going to change
about our button regardless of the color
and the context and so we start off with
like a prototype placeholder button uh
placeholder
selector and this is all the stuff
that's just going to undo what browsers
do
by default to buttons and kind of add
all the stuff that isn't going to change
like our font and our border radius
stuff like that and so now when we write
our our sas we can extend that button
placeholder and so we can work in sort
of a object-oriented modular approach
in our sas and then when it gets output
to css it's done in a performant way so
you can see here instead of copying
those 16 or so properties we actually
just increase the selector chain and so
this is one of the more powerful things
with preprocessors because you can the
way that you
write the source code isn't necessarily
how it gets compiled so you can write in
a way that is comfortable for you and
like makes sense from maintenance
perspective but then when it gets
compiled it's
it does what it needs to do to have the
smallest file size
uh and so now we have our base uh we and
so uh what we we extend the button
placeholder and we just add the unique
things about that button so
the only thing that's different is is
the background color here and we
actually we're already
running into a problem here because we
as i said before we want our dark
buttons they have light text and our
light text the light buttons have dark
text so let's see how we can use sas to
automate that translation process so
that individual developers can't uh
can't screw it up basically
so we can use a built-in sas function to
compare color lightness there's a
function called lightness that returns a
value between 0 and 100 just based on
like the hsl value of that color and so
here we just do some simple logic and
we're saying if the color is greater
than 50 so if the background color is a
light color we want to return dark text
and you know vice versa
so now our text color gets set
programmatically instead of
setting that color explicitly we call a
function and give it the background
color and then so you see on the right
here when our css gets compiled uh that
decision gets made for us and we don't
have to worry about like if an
individual developer is going to read
our style guide properly or not so sas
allows us to abstract design logic and
this is a really powerful tool because
we can we can abstract this stuff so
these change these uh decisions happen
behind the scenes and so also later on
if like you know our marketing
department comes in like you know it
really should be like four four four not
three three three that a b tests better
uh we can change that in one place and
then when we recompile all these changes
get made automatically
so
now that we have our base and some
simple design logic let's talk about how
to translate two
commonly used
layer styles from photoshop and how to
convert them to css we're going to start
with drop shadow and how to turn that
into a into a css box shadow and so this
is a css conference so i assume you've
all written a box shadow before but just
to make sure we're on the same page
the css syntax we have x and y offset
the blur radius is spread radius and
then a color
and so this is and this is what
photoshop gives us which is is pretty
similar but there are some important
differences color and opacity is
straightforward and spread and size are
pretty close to what we need but the the
big difference here and what we're going
to talk about is angle and distance and
so photoshop
hasn't it uses angle and distance to to
set the the size of our shadow instead
of just a straight up x and y offset
and so you probably you might not know
right now but at some point your like 15
year old self knew how to do this
and uh so basically we have an angle and
a distance which
is so we have a right triangle and so to
convert this from photoshop to css we
just uh we need to find missing sides of
a triangle so good old sokatoa
comes to play here uh when i when i was
like building these slides i was going
to make a joke about like oh the only
thing i remember from trigonometry is
sokatoa but then that that actually
ended up being exactly what i needed and
so
i didn't even realize it until i was
like wait okay yeah so anyway um our
our x offset is our is our adjacent side
of the triangle and our y offset is the
opposite side and so um
uh i i don't remember too much about
trigonometry but um but so there's these
uh basic formulas come into play where
it's just cosine of the angle times the
distance for the x offset the sine of
the angle times the distance for the y
offset
we can create a function that takes all
the values that were that are in the
photoshop layer style and does all these
conversions automatically and then
returns a list of values that turns into
a valid css syntax and so this has
actually been bundled as a
compass extension that you can that you
can download on github i was i was
working on it myself but then i was
doing some research for this talk and
somebody had already pretty much done
the exact same thing i had so i'm i'm
linking to their stuff
because why reinvent the wheel
so so now let's add the box shadow r
button we can take these values and
put them right into
our sas code using these functions and
then when it gets compiled into css we
have a valid box shadow so now our
button has a nice subtle drop shadow in
the normal state and then an inset
drop shadow in the active state and so
um we so now we we have confidence that
this drop shadow is exactly what our
designer intended because we're using
the same values that they put in the
photoshop
and so we'll go over text shadow because
this is kind of a freebie one um
the uh
all the math is the same for text shadow
obviously but the only difference
between uh text shadow and box shadows
that in css the spread radius is uh not
used by text shadow for some i'm
actually i don't know why but it's just
not there so um so this function
takes the photoshop uh takes the the
list that we return for this box shadow
and it just breaks up that list sas can
can manipulate lists kind of like arrays
so we're returning just the values that
we're omitting the the fourth value
which is the spread radius so that it
returns a valid text shadow
value and so again we're going to add
this to our button we're going to put in
the values directly from photoshop and
then when we get
then what gets output is a valid text
shadow so now we have a text shadow that
alternates when we click on it it just
goes from top to bottom so
giving the
illusion of depth
so so we have our shadows and now let's
talk about
how to convert a gradient overlay to
linear gradient and so this is a little
more complex this is the uh the hard
mode of the talk
but so again you guys have all probably
written a linear gradient before but to
make sure we're on the same page we
start with an angle or keyword which is
the direction of the gradient and then a
series of color stops
and so photoshop
what they give us is color and opacity
which again is you know straightforward
stuff and then our gradient which can be
a simple two color fade or it can be
something crazy like many many stops
then we have the angle which is the
direction and then the scale which is
the size of the gradient photoshop
allows you to create gradient overlays
that are larger or smaller than the
containing element
and so
angle you think at first maybe is pretty
straightforward we might be able to just
actually put in that value in the in the
css but um surprise there are some
browser inconsistencies here
um the vendor prefixed version of linear
gradient zero degree points to east but
uh in the in the unprefixed version zero
degree equals north and in photoshop
actually the the vendor prefixes is the
same as the photoshop version so we have
a lot of inconsistencies of what zero
degrees actually where that actually
points and so
how i've gone around this is i created a
function that that converts the angle to
um to a keyword when possible so if um
if the angle is is like in a cardinal or
ordinal
distance like 0 45 90 degrees it'll
convert it to a keyword but otherwise it
assumes that you want the unprefixed
version of the angle and so it subtracts
90 degrees from it so this i've never
most of the time whenever i've worked
with a designer it's uh
you know they're working from like top
or left or bottom so this has never been
a problem in real life before but there
are there is some limitations to to what
this conversion can do
but then so let's move on the scale
scale is a little more complex because
we want it to be we want it to grow and
shrink and so at first you might be like
well we'll just use the uh the
background size property but really we
want to write this as a function and
functions only return one value we can't
return uh two different properties
but the way around this is to actually
to the chain to manipulate our our color
stops and like where they are and so in
css you're actually allowed to have
stops that are less than zero percent or
greater than a hundred percent so if we
wanted to scale
um something to this gradient to 150
percent say we still want the middle to
be in the middle of our element so we'd
actually start at negative 25 percent
and go to 125
and um i i worked out this formula
myself because i couldn't i couldn't
find it by googling and uh this this
actually ended up being the hardest part
of this talk is working out this formula
so i'm really proud of it
but
so now we um so so now we need to take
all of our color stops and we need to
manipulate them based on our scale and
the way we do that with sas is uh we're
going to put our gradient colors and our
gradient stops into two different lists
and then we're going to use a for loop
just you know just like any other
programming language and we're going to
go through all those colors and we're
going to manipulate that stop based on
the scale and so we're going to sort of
break those apart and then rebuild a new
list that
that is in
that is what css needs to create a
linear gradient so this works for simple
gradients like a simple black to white
fade or if your designer is on lsd and
wants to do something super psychedelic
you can put is in many color stops you
can mess with the the direction and the
scale and no matter how complex of a
gradient you have in photoshop it'll
convert to css perfectly
and so now so let's do the same thing
we've done uh with all the other stuff
we're going to add the linear grain to
our button we're going to put in the
values that our designer wanted and then
when it converts to css plot twist
something went wrong
and
so uh the the gradient looks right it
goes from you know dark to light but the
color values are incorrect and so
there's been a piece of uh our photoshop
layer styles that we've been ignoring
this whole time
blend modes and so let's talk about
blend modes real quick blend modes are
you know they're a way to combine two
different colors a background and a
foreground color together
using different mathematical functions
and so
when i was
kind of working out trying to figure out
a way to programmatically solve these
problems that didn't have to rely on
on just
style guides you know when i was reading
about blend modes they're like oh it's
all just math functions like the light
bulb went off in my head i was like oh
well they're just math functions then we
can create you know we can create this
in sas we can recreate all these things
so these are three examples of um of
common blend modes the first one is uh
normal which is like no blend mode
actually so it just returns the
foreground color so what you what you
put in is what you get but the second
one is uh our multiply blend mode which
is a a darkening blend mode and this
combines the two colors together to
create kind of a nice
like a dark rusty sort of
um
more a darker color basically
and so finally but what our designers
wanted us to use is uh the overlay blend
mode which is a contrast blend mode so
the light colors get lighter and the
dark colors get darker it's uh it's
actually a pretty sexy blend mode i
think overlay is one of the best
uh but so uh there are a few limitations
with these uh blend mode functions you
have to know the foreground color and
the background color ahead of time and
photoshop all that stuff is sort of done
on the fly
um so for like drop shadows and stuff
like that
blend modes might not be a good choice
because they're outside of the element
so you don't necessarily know what the
background color is going to be but for
gradient overlays we know what our base
background color is and we know the
gradient that we want to put in front of
it so blend modes work perfectly there
so let's uh update our gradient overlay
conversion and so this time instead of
we're going to loop through all the
colors but instead of just returning
that color what we're going to do is
we're going to blend it with our
background color first and then we're
going to return that blended color and
so
this has been i turned this into a
compass extension too so if you want to
use this
you can go on my github account and
check it out
but so let's put that into our our
project now and if we when we use those
blend modes and we compile our css our
button looks perfect so now we've
created a toolkit that allows us to
translate our designs from photoshop to
css flawlessly with you know 100
confidence and so we used like we used
to have a problem where like every time
a button got created on the site we'd
have to go through and do visual qa and
there were so many times where it was
just like well the drop shadow isn't
right but now with these with sass and
with the uh with these functions we we
can just have confidence that
everything's going to work perfectly
and so no project is complete without a
little bit of refactoring so let's uh go
and see how we can make things uh work a
little bit better
um
there's a lot of redundancy here like
there's a lot of like the background
color is is uh repeated a bunch of times
and if we wanted to make a new button
we'd have to copy all this but what we a
better way to do it would be to
take all that code and put it into a mix
and that takes a background color as a
as a parameter and so now we can style a
button with one line of code
and
creating new buttons stuff that like
buttons and colors uh that we didn't
think of originally is easy and all of
our design logic is always followed and
we can be confident that everything
works perfectly which i think is pretty
badass
so um so this this is kind of shows the
power of sas and the way that like once
you start using preprocessors how you
can start thinking about um
css differently and how you can think
about
designing your site i think
with preprocessors we can we we should
start relying less on
style guides and designers and
developers should be working together to
build reusable systems to translate
their designs flawlessly it means we can
work faster and we can also be more
confident that our subtle design details
are going to translate perfectly
thanks guys